have you heard what rap sounded like in
the
1940s yes just come on Brothers if you
want to hear a story about that preacher
and the bear gather round boys I don't
want you to miss none of this year's
story because it goes like this that's a
recording from 1945 called preacher and
the bear from the gospel group The
jubileers and the Cadence and flow
sounds incredibly similar to this hit
song from 1979
Rappers Delight by the Sugar Hill Gang
was the first rap single to reach the
top 40 charts when rappers alive was
released hip hop and his four main
elements DJing graffiti b-boying and
mcing or rapping have long already been
established in New York City but for the
rest of the world hearing Rappers
Delight for the first time rapping was
new or was it because preacher in the
Bear by the jubileers was recorded over
30 years earlier